don't avoid door
just regarding
Darth Vader's glove there's an entire
story around Darth Vader's glove which
technically is a Mandalorian crush gaunt
that Star Wars fandom for you they track
the provenance of every individual item
of clothing it's like antiques roadshow
with more blaster fire at any rate Darth
Vader's Mandalorian crush God was pulled
through a wormhole during the explosion
of the Death Star two at the Battle of
Endor and transferred to the Mon
Calamari homeworld of dak some more
stuff happens to it but frankly I'm
exhausted just getting to that point
lack of paper think about it when in the
Star Wars movies does anyone ever use
paper they never write grocery lists or
make origami swans origami minox
originally there was officially no paper
in the Star Wars universe which explains
the lack of recycling bins on the
Millennium Falcon however some authors
eventually took it upon themselves to
introduce paper like in the touching
scene in assaulted Selonia or c-3po
scrapbooks words for cutting off
people's body parts lightsaber combat
has been so virulent Lee documented that
basically anything a Jedi does while
holding a lightsaber has a
thousand-year-old history and a dumb
pseudo Japanese name case in point Cho
my the Jedi term for chopping off a
dude's hand there's also Chosun the Jedi
term for chopping off a dude's arm and
Cho mock which is this kind of catch-all
term for just chopping off dude parts
usually legs I find myself wondering how
often this actually comes up did yet I
say oh yeah I totally chose on that guy
oh yeah none of that was each oh my
stuff when I Chow its Sun all the way
one arm the one-armed wampa speaking of
limb removal okay Empire Strikes Back
seems pretty straightforward Luke gets
smacked by wampa Luke escape from the
wampa Luke goes and takes a nap inside a
tauntaun but of course it's never that
simple it turns out that the wampa that
Luke sliced the arm off of which by the
way is not the same wampa for
some reason that smack him across the
face survives and goes on to get the
catchy nickname of one arm and then
leads a whole band of wamba's and then
eventually it's killed by Luke when he
comes back to Hoth some years later so
now you know this whole intricate back
story involving a minor character one
that in the end doesn't make the tiniest
bit of difference welcome to fandom the
star wars holiday special even if you're
not a Star Wars fan you may have heard
of this abomination of television
programming a special that served us
such sweet meats as Chewbacca
celebrating life day with his father
itchy and his son lumpy it also featured
Harvey Korman playing a forearm
celebrity chef named Gore manda this
show is universally reviled in part
because it fails to treat the menu with
sufficient respect and also because it
sucks except for the one little tiny
animated bit with Boba Fett now what
part of this horrible cheesy low-budget
television special would you expect
would be official canon in the Star Wars
universe the answer all of it life day
canonical itchy lumpy canonical Harvey
Korman in drag is an official part of
the Star Wars universe continuity kills
the one plus one bar